I'm sorry to report that the
new Cold War between China
and the United States has reached
the pandas.
These very cute, lovely
giant pandas are famous
and they are down the street at the zoo
in Washington, D.C.
and they have been since the ‘70s
when Richard Nixon went to China,
and as a gesture of friendship,
China gave us two pandas.
[Pat Nixon] I am pleased to accept the precious gift
of the panda
from the government
of the People's Republic of China.
We've had these two pandas at our zoo
for the last 50 years,
and now they're going home forever.
China practices
panda diplomacy,
giving pandas to countries
around the world
that they're friends with.
If you make China mad,
they might take away your pandas.
And that's potentially
what's going on here.
No one knows exactly why they didn't
renew the lease for the pandas
to stay at our zoo.
but many experts think that it's
because of the rising
tensions
between the United States and China.
So, if you're here in D.C.
and you love pandas,
you've got a few more
months to say goodbye.